[Music]
the david pakman show at david
pakman.com as i told you months ago he
would be doing it Bernie Sanders has
announced he is running for president he
announced in exactly the month February
2019
that I was told by someone close to
Bernie in 2018 that he would be doing it
the part that hasn't worked out as
predicted is that when I was told Bernie
would be announcing in February 2019 the
idea was that it would be one of the
first announcements and in fact he is
something like the I don't know roughly
tenth or twelfth Democratic candidate to
declare that he is seeking the
Democratic nomination in 2020 can we say
that bernie is now the front-runner I
don't know let's think it through I mean
the difference is from 2016 for sure
Bernie coming into the beginning of the
primary process with way more name
recognition I mean just exponentially
more than in 2016 he's known now within
the United States Senate or by the
United States of America as being the
farthest left senator within the United
States Senate that's a difference from
2016 and there's also this big
contingent that believes Bernie Sanders
would have defeated Trump in 2016 had he
been the nominee rather than Hillary
Clinton so that all is in favor of
Bernie now being the de facto
frontrunner on the other side of this is
a contingent and I don't know how big it
is I'm trying to assess how big it is
that's quite frankly furious with Bernie
Sanders because they some believe cost
Hillary Clinton the presidency in 2016 I
don't believe that but there's a
contingent that does believe that all
sorts of progressives on my Facebook
page saying
don't know who they're voting for but
they're definitely not voting for Bernie
some mentioning this thing about they
are Democrats and Bernie isn't so that
is is the reason some are citing that
they will not be supporting Bernie
Sanders in 2020 my message to people who
are really angry with Bernie is that
medicare-for-all being talked about as
much as it's being talked about today by
the Democratic candidates is because of
Bernie Sanders tuition free college
being discussed today in the way that it
is is because of Bernie Sanders in 2016
people like Alexandria Acacio Cortes and
that contingent in Congress today is
significantly a Bernie Sanders is
significantly responsible for that
movement which led to the election of
many of those candidates the idea of not
taking PAC money something we can
connect to Bernie Sanders so for me
right now it's not really that important
whether he is the front-runner or not he
certainly no longer the underdog as he
may have been considered in 2016 he is
without a doubt a top contender Cory
Booker Peter Budaj edge Julian Castro
John Delaney Tulsi Kirsten Gillibrand
Klobuchar Andrew yang Bernie is
certainly immediately ahead of them I
would put him along with Elizabeth
Warren and Kamala Harris probably as the
frontrunner right now but I don't even
think that's really the important
conversation to be having at this point
in time because frontrunners in February
of the year before the election don't
typically end up being the nominees now
typically kind of goes out the window
Donald Trump is President of the United
States but think back to Richard
Gephardt or John Edwards so I don't
think it's particularly useful to say
who's the front-runner right now what we
can do is look at data on his first day
in only the first four hours raising
money today Bernie Sanders has already
matched the campaign donations that
Kamala Harris received in her entire
first
day after announcing in just four hours
so there's no question here that Bernie
Sanders very quickly is towards the
front I think that the the real
questions are going to be has Bernie
Sanders done damage to himself by virtue
of being so successful in 2016 and what
I mean by that is in 2016
Bernie talking about Medicare for all
tuition free college higher marginal tax
rates on the rich he was an outlier in
discussing that now that those ideas
thanks to Bernie have been so much
further mainstreamed he no longer stands
out as the only candidate who supports
those things now of course with Medicare
for all there is a difference between
the Bernie Sanders position which is
Medicare for all as the way and here's
how we would pay for it and here's a
bill I've already introduced to do it
versus more moderate centrist Democrats
who are sort of playing coy and saying
truer Medicare for all would be nice but
I just don't think it's gonna happen and
here's some tweaks we can make to
Obamacare so we have Bernie to thank for
a lot of that conversation I think that
it may well become an issue that Bernie
Sanders is not a democrat but caucuses
with Democrats in the Senate that's
something I'm already seeing a lot of
discussion of on social media I think
that much like with Elizabeth Warren's
DNA test Fiasco I think that Bernie
Sanders and allegations of sexism not by
him but within the ranks of a 2016
campaign is probably going to be made an
issue by some of his opponents and my
advice right now would be let's continue
assessing the candidates on their
platforms let's start to think about
what their candidacies would look like
up against Donald Trump I think it's
okay to start considering that at this
point and don't try to reason with
people who are super Pro aoc but are
saying they hate Bernie because they
were born out of the same movement and I
think that that is how the left will
destroy itself we don't want to fall Vic
thumbs to the narcissism of small
differences and that's a phenomena that
I'm going to be talking about a little
bit later on in the program and maybe on
a live stream this evening as well so
we'll continue following the early
candidacy of Bernie Sanders not a
surprise that he announced more
surprising that he is only like the
tenth or twelfth candidate to make the
announcement okay I'm still preparing a
story on the case involving actor Jesse
Smollett it was initially reported that
he was the victim of a homophobic attack
that involved a rope around his neck and
a chemical thrown at him and attackers
yelling this is Magga
country and we now have more and more
reason to believe that the truth of the
incident is that the entire thing may
have been a staged attack I've been
waiting to do a full story about it
because I'm trying to figure out the
full truth of what exactly took place
but what I have for you today that I do
want to talk about is a really
cringe-worthy video a face-planting
video of 2020 Democratic candidate
Kamala Harris being asked about this and
she really doesn't handle it well it's
actually hard for me to imagine her
handling it even worse previously
senator Kamala Harris called the
Smollett incident a modern day lynching
she tweeted shortly after it took place
this was an attempted modern day
lynching no one should have to fear for
their life because of their sexuality or
color of their skin we must confront
this hate perfectly reasonable thing to
say based on what was known at the time
but of course as I mentioned it's now
appearing more and more that the attack
may have been staged so predictably
Kamala Harris was asked about it asked
about her tweet and she implodes she
handles it terribly first she pretends
not to know about the tweet being
referred to okay maybe she forgot but
then as she's asked again about it she
looks around and what it looks like to
me is that she's looking for a staffer
or a handler or an aide to run
interference to tell the reporter she's
not going to answer the question to say
we've got to go sorry submit your
questions in writing which is just the
worst look in this situation when you
ask the question and you condescendingly
look away for someone to pull the
reporter away then look back and laugh
it just looks really bad but then she
just stutters and stammers and says well
facts are unfolding and it is one of the
worst politician responses I could
imagine in the situation let's take a
look at it which tweet what we are the
about saying that it is a modern day
lynching that sorry a smaller okay so I
will say this about that case I think
that the facts are still unfolding and
I'm very concerned about obviously
totally cringe-worthy and the worst part
is the looking for someone to take the
reporter away or to take her away or to
step into the middle of it why not just
say listen under this administration
we've seen a coalescing and a catalyzing
of the worst extremist hate elements
we've seen racist incidents we've seen
anti-semitic incidents we've seen the
embolden of the white nationalist right
the president saying he would pay the
legal bills of supporters who punch the
opposition protesters at his events I
commented on this on the basis of what
was reported initially sometimes cases
are not what they seem this may be one
of those cases but for the most part
false crime reporting and staged crimes
are incredibly rare we'll eventually
know the truth if this was a staged
attack the perpetrators need to be
punished
the law prescribes punishment for such
perpetrators that's it like I can't
imagine Pat any worse response
particularly when there is such a simple
and coherent response that she could
have given especially because it's not
like Camilla Harris did anything wrong
by sending out that tweet I mean she was
reporting on what we all thought was
true at the time may still have been
true but we just don't know the veracity
of the claims haven't been verified yet
so she could just say no comment for the
time being she wants to wait until she
hears all the facts out that's all you
to do even no comment would have been
boring but it would have been better
than what she did and it reminds me of
when there are false rape allegations
and reporters go to people who said
rapists should be punished this is
horrible
and of course the answer is false rape
allegations are criminal people who do
them should be punished
they're also extraordinarily rare if
somebody makes a false rape allegation
if somebody staged an incident like this
they should be punished let's not get
distracted from the reality that most
rape allegations are true and that most
crime reports are not crimes staged by
the person claiming to be a victim of
the crime so just a total misstep and
quite frankly sort of surprising for
someone as seasoned and typically well
prepared as Kamala Harris is what do you
think happened here let me know and if
this was a good response and I'm missing
something
please let me know I'm on Twitter at D
Pakman the show is on twitter at david
pakman show the david pakman show at
david pakman.com
[Music]
[Music]
the david pakman show at david
pakman.com the David Pakman show is
viewer and listener supported media you
can support us by signing up for a
membership at WWN pakman.com today I
want to say thanks to our newest member
of the day Cynthia Stilwell Cynthia
thank you so much also want to say
thanks to our longtime sustaining member
of the day Patrick Berg who has been
with us almost five years great day for
new members Cynthia and Patrick thank
you you can join them at a 40% discount
if you so please if you desire the
discount by using the coupon code this
is 2020 when you pick the membership of
your choice at join pakman.com ok I told
you when Donald Trump declared this
bogus national emergency over the
non-existent crisis at the us-mexico
border that there would be legal
challenges and indeed there are 16
states have now filed the lawsuit over
Donald Trump's declaration of a national
emergency to try to commandeer money
from the military and the Department of
Defense to build a border wall 16 states
Colorado Connecticut Delaware Hawaii
Illinois Maryland Maine Michigan
Minnesota
yes Minnesota almost at Minneapolis
Nevada New Jersey New Mexico New York
Oregon and Virginia all participating in
this lawsuit which claims primarily that
this declaration of a national emergency
is a misuse of presidential power and
there's a couple of different ways that
this can be argued and we'll see as this
progresses which is the path that
actually is employed here number one is
the argument that historically and I
told you this yesterday in part
historically national emergencies have
been used to expedite either funding or
action on issues that have bipartisan
support
so sanctions on particular people around
the world
delivering aid somewhere declaring a
particular situation a disaster zone or
a humanitarian crisis or whatever the
idea is there is bipartisan support and
the declaration of the national
emergency helps to further the position
of the House and Senate in order to more
quickly achieve something Donald Trump's
doing the opposite here there's no
congressional consensus for funding his
border wall Donald Trump has chosen to
use the declaration of a national
emergency not to more quickly do what
Congress is trying to do but to actually
do the opposite of what Congress has
shown a willingness to do to circumvent
the hesitation of Congress the house in
the Senate to fund Donald Trump's bogus
border walls so as I said if you're a
small government conservative you should
be furious at what Donald Trump is doing
if you believe in checks and balances
you should be furious about this
decision if you are against expanding
executive branch power and the power of
the office of the presidency which many
small government conservatives claim to
be against then you have to be against
this if you don't even care about any of
that stuff and you just believe in facts
and logic you have to realize that there
is no factual case to be made that there
is a crisis on the southern border the
facts just don't bear it out and I won't
even repeat the full list again because
it's it's total broken record
circumstances at this point on that
issue now there may also be lawsuits
coming from red states the actual border
states were the where the wall would go
because there are right-wingers who made
generally speaking believe that there's
an immigration crisis or like the idea
of a border wall but there are
right-wingers who own land on the border
who don't want the government taking
their land for the wall particularly on
the basis of a national emergency
declared by the president going around
the will of Congress what is really
important here is that the lawsuits
aren't about the wall per se they are
lawsuits about executive branch
overreach on the basis of a
declaration by the president seizing
money and seizing potentially property
land and the argument pad is that this
makes it a constitutional issue and the
best-case scenario is that this takes
years to resolve nothing gets built and
eventually a Democratic president says
there's no more emergency and we're not
trying to build the wall I see that as
the sort of best path forward to tie
this thing up indefinitely that does
sound like the right path forward and
everyone knew that these lawsuits were
going to happen including the President
himself he mentioned that during his
national emergency speech and honestly
if the courts do strike this down in
time I don't think he'll care that much
I think he just wanted to deliver this
campaign promise to his supporters and
he's going to come to the polls in 2020
and say that I did what I could I tried
to build the wall through Congress I
tried to do it through a national
emergency declaration and the court
struck me down and everyone's against me
but his supporters will still do this as
a as an attempt at winning like he'd
like he'd tried to fulfil his campaign
promise isn't it sort of weird that they
claim to be against socialism but a lot
of them are okay with the government
seizing both taxpayer land and taxpayer
money by circumventing Congress to build
a wall aren't those the bad elements of
socialism that they claim to be again
it's a very very strange thing we'll see
what happens now this could be you know
we've been reporting on it daily since
the declaration of the national
emergency but we may get to a point
where there's very little to say about
it because it's just going to be tied up
in courts for years which i think would
actually be a pretty good outcome okay
yesterday we went through the content of
Donald Trump's speech declaring a
national emergency to try to get the
border wall built and when we talked
about this yesterday I mentioned to you
that right after his Rose Garden speech
declaring this emergency and talking
about how this is all so important and
it's all got to be done
Donald Trump immediately went down to
one of his golf clubs and was spotted at
the omelet station and apparently I'm
not pronounced
it correctly and we'll deal with that
later on in the show and he's pictured
grabbing an omelet before or after his
golfing and of course when you say I'm
having an emergency that's not usually
followed by I need a ham and cheese
omelet and three diet cokes immediately
it's usually followed by something
related to the emergency that you have
declared right the us-mexico border
emergency which requires commandeering
funds circumventing the will of Congress
it's even worse than we thought because
now we have found out that Donald Trump
not only golfed right after declaring
the national emergency he golfed three
days in a row three days in a row of a
national emergency so important that it
requires as far as Trump is concerned
circumventing the decisions made by the
US House and Senate and he couples them
with three days of golfing Saturday
reportedly included six hours of golf
interesting detail Trump has been
showing up to start golfing around 9:00
a.m. each of these three days Trump
doesn't even show up to the Oval Office
in the same building where he lives
until the level at 11:00 a.m. on a
normal day he has now made depending on
which numbers you look at between a
hundred and fifty nine and a hundred and
seventy two visits to golf clubs during
his presidency this is more vacation
than most people take in multiple years
who were not the President of the United
States and of course Trump has also made
money by making these golf trips to his
golf clubs one example is that over the
weekend a Chinese delegation met with
Trump not at the White House but at his
mar-a-lago Resort Trump is playing golf
and making money personally while a
national emergency
supposedly warrants getting around
Congress to commandeer money from the
military and the Department of Defense I
as I was reading about this it reminded
me of this infamous George W Bush moment
where he delivered an impactful
statement about terror right before
teeing off on the golf course we must
the terror I call upon all nations to do
everything they can to stop these
terrorist killers thank you now watch
this Drive
there you go I don't actually think
Trump believes this is really an
emergency Pat I'm curious what you think
I believe Trump believes three million
Hillary voters voted illegally in 2016 I
believe that because he's privately
continued to say it even after the
conversation was out of the media I
think Trump probably believes in real
life that the Russia probe is a
witch-hunt
I don't believe Trump actually thinks
there is a border crisis that warrants a
national emergency he even said during
the Rose Garden speech I didn't have to
do this I did this because I feel like
building the wall more quickly
I believe Pat that Trump knows deep down
this one is not real yeah I think he
just wants to rally and satisfy his face
of supporters and this vacation time to
me it sounds like he sees himself as
having completed the job like he worked
so hard to try to get wall funding
during the government shutdown to buckle
and then that three week period when we
didn't know if the government was going
to be shut down again that now he
deserves a vacation because he did what
he had to do he declared the national
emergency and now we're moving on he can
take a break
whatever Trump thinks we've got to hope
that the courts are going to stop this
absolutely ridiculous power grab and
misuse of the national emergency
declaration either way under the
best-case scenario for the wall builders
not much of this wall is ever going to
be built even if Donald Trump has six
more years as president eight billion
dollars would in the best case scenario
build some tiny piece of the wall it
would take years lawsuits will slow it
down and the next Democratic president
will simply be able to end it so this
could change but unless something
radically changes even on the basis of
this declaration almost no wall is
actually going to be built and then that
transforms this from an actual
discussion about immigration policy and
what can be done pragmatically to just
political posture
about who can claim victory on the wall
as pat pointed out earlier and what that
means is that every American loses we
all lose when these become merely
political footballs that are thrown back
and forth make sure to follow me on
instagram i'm on instagram at david
pakman also on the david pakman show
instagram page we have a very funny
photo collage i i'm actually calling it
a photo essay from producer pat of
producer max having string cheese at
david packard david pakman show studios
and it was Max's birthday earlier this
week and to celebrate Max's birthday on
the at David Pakman show Instagram
account there's a photo essay by
producer Pat which I am just calling Pat
string cheese 2019 is how I would like
to describe it and shout out the
producer max I would say that he is on
the Mount Rushmore of current David
Pakman show producers yes and he's the
only person on that proverbial Mount
Rushmore interestingly enough all right
let's take a break we are going to talk
next about FOMO the fear of missing out
and it's going to be a really great
interview coming up in mere minutes
after this quick break the david pakman
show at david pakman.com
[Music]
welcome back to the David Pakman show
it's great to welcome to the program
today spend Brinkmann who is a professor
of psychology at the University of
Aalborg Denmark also author of books
including stand firm and the joy of
missing out spend it's really great to
speak to you today
well I'm glad that you invited me thank
you so let's talk a little bit about the
joy of missing out and sort of the other
side of that which is the fear of
missing out or FOMO as many Americans
now as sort of understand the term first
and foremost what are we really
describing when we talk about the fear
of missing out what's happening sort of
psychologically that influences people
yeah I mean the fear of missing out is
sort of a mentality that we have
developed in our consumer society I
would say with a constant doubt about
what we are doing what we are consuming
what we're buying
who we are with in marriages and
relationships our jobs no matter what we
do we can post the question to ourselves
is this the right thing for me and that
you know gives this fear the question am
I missing out on something that is more
important that that could potentially
you know be important to me realize my
inner potentials to to grow as a person
or something like that and in addition
we have developed as we all know now
technologies digital technologies in
particular social media that enable us
to access almost anything all the time
our relationships new use knowledge
about all sorts of things so all these
things taken together really gives us
this fear of missing out
in the you know short term but also in
the longer term in in our lives and it's
deeply dissatisfying
to us it makes us unhappy it makes us
miserable and it's really difficult to
do something about because it's so
ingrained in our culture and in our
technologies so I want to get in a
second to the way in which modern
technology is making this worse but
before we do that thinking back a little
bit is there any way that this fear of
missing out might have at some point in
human history been some kind of an
evolutionary advantage is that a
possibility yeah it certainly is it's
always a bit risky to speculate about
what life was like 200,000 years ago in
East Africa and you know we have all the
myths of evolutionary psychology
I mean I'm absolutely certain that we
come from East Africa so to say but it's
not given how much we can actually take
from the knowledge of human beings as a
species and conclude about current life
today but I guess you're right that you
know our activities as explorers of this
world what's around the next hill is an
important evolutionary motor if you will
and of course this was developed in
times when resources were scarce where
we had to struggle and fight to to
obtain goods and and and you know food
and all sorts of things that we need to
survive but now all these things are not
scarce at least not in most parts of the
world we have plenty of resources and
I'm not just talking about food but all
sorts of products knowledge is you know
consumer goods of all kinds so the
problem is really something else it's
how to develop the art of self-restraint
the art of missing out and saying no to
all these invitation
that we're constantly faced with yeah so
I mean like in my professional life at
several years ago I would basically say
yes to everything part of it was the
fear that whatever I turned down was
going to be like the big break the
opportunity to sort of get to the next
level and over time partially because of
the growth of my program but also
because I've just kind of developed as a
person I'm much more comfortable saying
no to things but what I think might have
been useful to me seven or eight years
ago would have been some kind of a
system to better that evaluates when
should you say yes and when should you
say no so like what what might be an
infrastructure that people could apply
to their lives to better decide what it
makes sense to do and what it makes
sense to pass on yeah no this is an
extremely important question in my view
we see now all sorts of programs like
you know simple living 10 or 15 years
ago is now being rehabilitated we have
Marie Kondo yes
talking about decluttering your life we
have books about you know the art of
saying no and so this has become quite a
trend and I think it's important I think
we should listen to these voices because
they really do speak to something
important in our times but what I would
like to see and what I hope will happen
is that we discuss these things with
some sort of ethical foundation with
some sort of you know value basis and
just to give one example and I I don't
mean to say anything you know about
Marie Kondo but the question she wants
us to pose when we pick up our objects
is does it spark joy in me and now this
is a good question in a way but what if
this joy is momentary or what if it
doesn't spark joy me now but it might
tomorrow or I might have other reasons
to keep this object maybe because it
represents some symbolic value related
to my family or my history of whatever
I think we can only answer these
questions and develop the system that
you rightly long for in a way if we
understand that humans have commitments
we have obligations and and these
obligations and commitments are
basically what structure or should
structure our lives if we are to develop
this art of self-restrained as I like to
call it it's it's not just a matter it's
not it's not just a matter of doing as
little as possible and saying no to all
sorts of things
it's about as I see it moderation Palin
balancing between too much on the one
side and too little on the other and I
really think that you know ethics moral
philosophy can help us arbitrate and
navigate in these matters one of the
terms that I've discussed before with my
audience is the the term hedonic
adaptation which is often applied to the
cost of one's lifestyle in other words
if you're used to a $50,000 a year
lifestyle and then you get a raise to a
hundred thousand dollars and everything
in your life is adjusted to go with a
hundred thousand dollar lifestyle at a
certain point you will that will become
your new baseline
and you will not really experience any
subjective well-being that is different
from the $50,000 a year lifestyle does
that term apply to the fear of missing
out and the idea that if you start doing
much more that becomes your baseline and
you don't really feel any better yeah
absolutely and I do discuss this a bit
in the book the fact as you say that we
strive for something we we might obtain
it and then we get used to it and we
just develop a new baseline of happiness
or contentment or subjective well-being
that seems to be part of the human
condition and now we talked earlier
about our evolutionary past and in
evolutionary terms this is highly useful
because it means that if we experience
some trauma some loss and tragedy
we actually most of us quite quickly
bounce back to the baseline level and
that's quite good for us so we can keep
on living and and in producing and and
you know the nurturing our offspring and
so on but it's not good news when we
talk about peak experiences you know
joys and and good surprises like winning
in the lottery and stuff like that
because those joys are just as momentary
and we will quickly you know fall back
to some baseline of happiness and then
we might begin to wonder is something
wrong with me I just won the lottery I
just got the job that I wanted my
girlfriend just agreed to marry me and
and I might be happy for a week or two
and then everything is back to normal
and I think it will be very difficult to
break free from this hedonic treadmill
as some people also like to call it but
I think at least we can realize that
it's a fact of human nature it's a basic
fact of our psychology and then we might
be content you know we might not you
know explode with despair when realizing
that why do I not have these you know
huge bursts of happiness with all these
good things have happened to me well
because that's just life most of our of
our lives we live in some sort of middle
gray area concerning happiness and
that's just as it should be so maybe we
shouldn't focus as so much on you know
super happiness the subjective
well-being maybe we should focus more as
I said before on values on ethics on
what is meaningful I think that is a
much more useful and practical approach
to life trying to figure out what is
meaningful how to nurture your
relationships how to live up to the
obligations we have to other people and
doing important projects in our lives
and then from time to time we will feel
these you know bursts of happiness and
joy but more as a side effect I'm very
suspicious that we
you know chase these Pig experiences of
happiness directly I think when they
appear they appear as side effects of
you know truly meaningful human
activities but this is mainly mom what
my book is about it has become very
difficult to focus on these meaningful
human activities because of the fear of
missing out because of all the noise
that we hear you know all the
invitations we get from social media
from commercials in this consumer
society that we have created for
ourselves so in in the sort of limited
time that we have left can you now get
specifically into how social media and
the sort of scrolling social web sites
like Facebook and Twitter and Instagram
are worsening this problem yeah it's
sort of a technology designed like so
much else in our consumer societies to
to make us dissatisfied with what we
have we can never say when we scroll
down a you know Facebook feed or
something like that now I know enough
now I don't have to know anything else
because there's always something else to
see to you know to click to like to to
explore and so it's really designed to
make us unhappy with what we have and
what we see and to go and hunt more and
that is you know exploiting the general
mechanism that that we have as humans
and that we have seen in the past you
know 200 years really being articulated
and developed with consumer society that
if you're happy with what you have if
you're satisfied you really suffer from
you know advice it used to be a virtue
to be able to say well I'm happy I'm
content but if you're happy and content
then you no longer you know feed into
the machinery of the industry and so on
and so you need more you need something
else and yes the social media and the
digital technologies are simply just a
very visible symptom of that
I remember one ad from you know
Intercontinental Hotel the the you know
a big hotel chains of hotel and it said
you can't have a favorite place until
you've seen them all and this is like
the poetry of capitalism right it really
tells us something true in in quite a
poetic form but also something quite
tragic because the message really is you
can never have a favorite place because
you can never see them all and try to
translate that into jobs into life
projects into relationships you can
never have a favorite partner until
you've had them all well obviously
that's meaningless but maybe that's what
we are thinking because it's what we
have been taught to to think when
developing this fear of missing out
we've been speaking with Sven Brinkman
who is professor of psychology at the
University of Aalborg Denmark also
author of the books stand firm and the
joy of missing out it's been really a
pleasure having you on thank you it was
a pleasure to talk to you the david
pakman show at david pakman.com
[Music]
the david pakman show at david
pakman.com
okay I want to talk today about
something called the narcissism of small
differences or the narcissism of minor
differences as it's sometimes known and
this would the announcement that Bernie
Sanders is running he's now in the
twenty twenty primary it's a really
important conversation for the left to
have and it's an important conversation
because of some of the factions that are
developing on the left in short terms in
sort of like the briefest way to define
this the narcissism of small differences
is when the small differences that
separate certain people are overstated
to such a degree that they appear to be
massive differences and cause conflict
when there really doesn't need to be any
conflict that this goes back to the
1920s and Freud actually but there's
lots of different interpretations as to
where this originally comes from but the
idea is we become narcissistic about our
own views on small differences with
other people why this exists is open to
some interpretation there's one idea
more from Freud that there's a kind of
satisfaction to humans of an inclination
to aggression a mild inclination to
aggression and if it seems like we agree
on 95% of stuff of political issues for
example something in us becomes
satisfied when we find something we can
be aggressive about or hostile about
with other people so we focus
disproportionately on the 5% difference
rather than the 95% agreement or
similarity another idea about where the
narcissism of small differences comes
from is that there's just a kind of
general desire to be different and so
when we see that we have a lot in common
with someone else we have a resistance
to feeling that we're just like them so
we will find small differences to argue
about so that we feel unique Christopher
Hitchens had many interesting
commentaries that sort of circled around
this idea the reason that this matters
is that when you become consumed by
minor differences
things start to become exclusionary I'm
separate from those who have this minor
disagreement with me and we start to
focus on the trivial and kind of miss
the forest for the trees to use a
metaphor so let's now look starting with
the 2020 primary at how this is starting
to manifest already it's a primary right
so we've got to make a choice between
the options we do have some duty to
figure out what are the differences
between the candidates and there are
important differences but then there's
also minor differences that are not
practically speaking super-important
let's look for example at Elizabeth
Warren and Bernie Sanders on policy
positions Bernie and Elizabeth Warren
are very very similar in terms of where
they've ended up now I've pointed out to
you Elizabeth Warren comes from the
center more and has been pulled to the
left bernie comes from more of a left
socialism perspective and has been
pulled towards pragmatism he and
Elizabeth Warren have basically ended up
in the same place on most policies not
on all great we don't have to go crazy
arguing about Warren versus Bernie in
the destructive way that I'm already
starting to see friends do on Facebook
they're two of the leftmost candidates
they are arguably the two left most
members of the United States Senate if
either of them won the primary I would
gladly vote for either let's not allow
narcissism over small differences to
cloud that they're not only obviously
better than Donald Trump but they're
mostly better than a lot of the other
Democratic candidates as well in
geopolitics we have lots of examples of
the narcissism of small differences the
partition of India and Pakistan is an
example that maybe is less well known
but a good example let's I mean I'll
take this head-on let's look at an
example that's related to me there are
people on the Left who disagree with me
about the israeli-palestinian conflict
let's explore this like adults for a
second since I know many of you are
probably already thinking about that
how significant our our difference is
really in practice I would imagine that
I and most of my audience agrees that
the current israeli-palestinian status
quo is unacceptable
I imagine that we mostly agree that
Benjamin Netanyahu is not going to be an
arbiter of peace in the Middle East I
think we all basically agree that the
Palestinian people are being treated
like crap as a result of what's going on
and we need the most direct path to
ending that that we can possibly find
I would assume my audience and I mostly
agree that the blockade on Gaza has to
be lifted as a top priority of whatever
agreement is made as soon as an
agreement as possible on settlements I
think my audience mostly agrees with me
that new settlements must stop and as
many as reasonably possible are going to
have to be dismantled as part of an
eventual long term peace deal where
might we disagree I've said that I think
there are probably some settlements that
might have to be land swapped in an
eventual agreement maybe some people in
the audience disagree with me about that
but it's a relatively minor difference
my audience and I are I believe on the
same page in opposition of moving the
American Embassy in Israel from Tel Aviv
to Jerusalem so in the end the
differences are relatively minor but
there is a tendency to focus on those
differences overstate them and end up
losing all possibility of sensible
conversation on that basis so what does
this mean for 2020 what does this mean
for the left going forward what this I
think means what I think the takeaway
has to be is let's understand that in
general the narcissism of small
differences is something that can be
destructive let's further our
understanding even in just thinking back
to the interview that I just did that
social media makes this way worse
because it leads to a situation where
oftentimes people are interacting on
social media only on the basis of the
small disagreements you're not likely to
tweet back and forth with people or to
simply comment on YouTube about how you
agree about ninety five percent on about
95 percent of issues with someone else
that's on YouTube or on Twitter you're
likely to engage only on those small
differences and that just exacerbates
the problem and the last thing I will
say is that as important as it is not to
fall into the trap of the narcissism of
small differences let's not mistake real
differences as small right so one
example Trump versus Hillary as we are
now seeing with the embarrassment of the
US on the world stage the Supreme Court
decisions that Donald Trump has made and
everything else
some people incorrectly assess the
difference between Trump and Hillary as
small in 2016 that's also a danger we
have to recognize serious differences
where they exist look forward to hearing
from you about this my favorite visual
of the week other than Donald Trump at
the omelet station at his Golf Club is
what happened at the Munich Security
Conference when Mike Pence mentioned
Donald Trump and what happened is
complete silence I'm gonna play a clip
for you here where you will see Mike
Pence vice president in Munich say
Lindsey Graham led this delegation to
the Munich Security Conference let's
thank him for that and then you will
hear clapping and then Mike Pence will
say also Donald Trump and then it's
complete and total silence during what
was supposed to be an applause line and
the audio is good enough but if you're
only listening on the radio or on the
podcast find the visual of this because
the visual just shows you the full scope
of it pence sort of looks around he's
not sure I mean he said an applause line
why is no one clapping the reason is
that the mango menace is increasingly an
object of ridicule around the world
let's take a look at the video I
especially want to invite all of you to
thanks
Lindsey Graham for leading this w
and today I've got all of the you on
three ingredients from a great champion
of freedom and a strong national defense
who has worked with these members of
Congress to strengthen America's
military might and to strengthen the
leadership of the free world I bring
greetings from the 45th President of the
United States of America President
Donald Trump oh it is just the best
everyone should be the glad that the
crowd didn't merely laugh at the mention
of Trump's name and what we're seeing
here it's just what's going on around
the world when it comes to world leaders
view of Trump it's mostly who cares
Trump's contributing nothing positive
internationally and I know when we play
this Pat that the committed trumpets
don't care but this is part of that
tenuous and strained relationship
between the US and European allies when
pen shows up and says France Germany and
the UK should pull out of the Iran
nuclear deal because we did world
leaders recognize that if Iran doesn't
violate the deal which they didn't it's
a really bad idea to pull out it makes
the u.s. look bad when they realized
that there's no point in even inviting
the United States Trump administration
to participate in discussions related to
climate change because Trump thinks it's
a hoax this is the point of view of the
rest of the world increasingly which is
it's not even laughing it's just who
cares about Trump part of the reason why
that video is so great it's because Mike
Pence actually looks surprised he's
shocked that people aren't clapping it
shouldn't be a surprise at all I don't
think like he should expect that
European leaders are not going to be on
his side in this one yeah US diplomatic
influence is on the decline US influence
around the world is on the decline were
no longer a part of the climate change
conversation the world knows that on
geopolitics Trump's priorities are
completely backwards he's compromised at
minimum by Vladimir Putin also possibly
by Saudi Arabia on technology on
high-speed trains on all sorts of stuff
we are falling
further and further behind the dollar as
I've been telling you for a year now is
less and less the transactional and
default currency for countries around
the world the world sees Trump pence as
phonies which they are they have no
business being in charge but it's having
a real-world impact and it is an
embarrassment when Trump administration
delegates including up to up to and
including Mike Pence and Donald Trump
themselves it's an embarrassment around
the world in the literal sense the UN
laughs the Munich Security Conference
simply doesn't even react to the
applause line of the great champion of
freedom and security Donald Trump it's
an absolute and total embarrassment okay
I got a ton of emails tweets and YouTube
comments yesterday when we covered
Donald Trump getting food at mar-a-lago
and this viral picture that we have
after he declared a national emergency
I said he's at the omelet station and a
lot of people said David that's not how
it's pronounced one of those people was
the egg man who we haven't heard from
for a while here's what the egg man said
hi I'm Paul talk to Dave English is my
second language there's Tom it's
pronounced omelet not omelet it does not
have three syllables in it please look I
don't mean to criticize you but I just
want you to tell me I'm not the only one
who corrected you on that they're twice
imal it's just if you're not scared to
say once and then run away from the mic
and then wait till tomorrow figure out a
safe don't double down anyway Darwyn
brother I'm gonna go get a bacon egg and
cheese omelet for breakfast yeah okay um
thank you Eggman Shalom to you I this is
how I've always said it and I think it
may be because the word is really a
French word and in Argentina in Spanish
it's basically the French pronunciation
so I guess is up so is do you say
omelette I it would just never occurred
to say it to me that way Pat you know as
a vegan I think I'm going to stay out of
this altogether I don't eat omelets I
don't know how to pronounce
omelette either one works for me I will
I I admit this is not a high priority
for me to correct I made an effort to
fully understand fewer verses less I
made an effort to say Nevada and Hawaii
as opposed to Nevada and Hawaii and
that's it i think i'm gonna continue
saying omelet and i love it
ok we've got a great bonus show for you
today i'm out of time but it's a good
one become a member become a patron much
more show coming up today if you want it
but you've got to listen to it or watch
it on the bonus show
the david pakman show at david
pakman.com
[Music]
you